I think I know how to spell pretty well
I'm pretty sure that's not how you spell
Magica but just saying of all the
thousands of letters we received there
was some kind of special and odd about
this next one can do anything can it do
miracles I'm only 12 years old so I was
not alive when some of the best games
ever made came out now a lot of them are
gone forever the player masterpiece like
for instance one of Tim Schafer's old
adventure games I would have to pirate
it and that's not nice
these is there anything you can do to
bring great games like one of Tim
Schafer's back from the dead
sincerely Sally th10 I think somebody's
throwing me okay so she was 12 at first
now she's 10 there's a fingerprint let's
move that over that's got knuckle hair I
think that's the 10 or 12 year old let's
pan it up a bit that's not a 12 year
olds beard okay bring it all the way on
that's Tim Mulligan shave
okay Sally all right we have some great
news for you and the fans after 15 years
Double Fine in tandem with our
third-party production team will be
remastering your classic adventure game
Grim Fandango
it will be coming exclusively to both
ps4 and PSVita thanks to the
relationship with our good friends at
Disney looks like it's time to get to
work Sally maybe some of the little
shaves
Sally Tim Sally Tim Sally you've also
told us that you guys love a wide range
of crazy and diverse games